ارتفع عدد ضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه التي
تضرب الولايات المتحده الى 48 قتيلا وذلك
بعد اعلان سلطات ولايه نيويورك ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا في مدينه
الى 25
وكشف موقع اوف لايت انه تم الغائه نحو
ثلاثه الاف رحله اليوم وتاجيل اكثر من
سبعه الاف رحله بسبب العاصفه الثلجيه
من واشنطن معنا مراسل الجزيره محمد العلمي
محمد عدد كبير من الوفيات هل مر الاسوا ام
ان الاسوء ما زال متوقع
عثمان مع الاسف ربما الاسوا ما زال متوقعا
بالنسبه لعدد الضحايا والقتلى والمتوقع ان
يرتفع خاصه في مدينه بافلو هذه المدينه
الواقعه في شمال شرق نيويورك على الحدود
مع كندا ربما هي الافضل بين المدن
الامريكيه سواء من حيث الخبره والتراكم
التاريخي في التعامل مع مثل هذه العواصف
او من حيث التجهيزات لكن كل تجهيزات وكل
خبره لم تساعد المدينه في مقاومه هذا
الاعصار بسبب قوته غير المسبوقه في تاريخ
المدينه نيويوركيا بعد سكان المدينه وجدوا
متجمدين حتى الموت في سياراتهم او في
بيوتهم التي انقطع عن تيار الكهربائي
ثلاثه من سكان المدينه على الاقل ماتوا
وهم يحاولون ازاحه الثلوج بسبب ازمات
قلبيه وبعد المرضى العاديين في بيوتهم
اتصلوا بمراكز الاستعجالات لكن همم سيارات
اسعاف كانت مدفونه تحت ثلوج ولما وبسبب
وعوره الطرق لم يستطيع عمال اغاثه
والاسعاف الوصول اليهم وهذا ما يفسر همم
ان اكثر او من نصف القتلى في هذا الاعصار
في الولايات
المتحدهم في مدينته بطلوا الان وهمم بعد
بدايه تحسن تدريجي همم في الاحوال الجويه
وارتفاع البطيء لدرجه الحراره همم بدا همم
مسؤوله المدينه في فتح بعض الطرق الى
المستشفيات الى دور العجزه والى الدور
التي انقطع عنها تيار الكهربائي لتفقد
السكان
وهذا ما يرشح ان عدد القتلى ربما يرتفع في
المستقبل القريب محمد العالمي من واشنط
شكرا جزيلا لك